[Música]
economía en directo América de Francia
24 Juan Pablo lucumí conmigo en el
estudio Juan Pablo bienvenidos ya
llegamos al viernes finalizando semana
Movida en Reino Unido no y comenzamos en
ese país porque hay cambios drásticos en
el Ministerio de economía Qué se sabe
hasta el momento pues Raúl buenos días
los medios británicos inicialmente como
la bbc o de Times revelar revelaron que
lo más seguro es que hoy salga de
funciones de la cartera de finanzas su
actual titular cuasi cuarte en qué
tiempo después lo confirmaron esto luego
de semanas turbulentas para cuartel pero
también para para la primera ministra
quién acabó de cumplir su primer mes en
el cargo pero que ha tenido que
enfrentar fuertes críticas cuando ambos
impulsaron un proyecto llamado mini
presupuesto que incluye un aumento del
gasto fiscal y recortes de impuestos lo
polémico de todo esto es que pues hubo
poca explicación de cómo se financiaría
el plan y el fondo monetario
internacional recomendó a Reino Unido
revisar dicho mini presupuesto además el
banco de Inglaterra tuvo que invertir en
la situación y pues tuvo que meter la
mano en todo esto sumado a todo lo demás
recordemos que esto trajo una caída
histórica de la libre de la libra
esterlina en los mercados y que esto lo
estuvimos reportando aquí muchas veces
le costó el puesto Juan Pablo Entonces
al ministro de economía de Reino Unido
Ahora sí hablemos de algunos rumores que
están afectando bastante los mercados
mundiales y es la llegada de una posible
recesión mundial por todo lo que está
pasando por la pandemia en fin a nivel
bursátil los ha afectado constantemente
y lo hemos estado reportando aquí pues
muchas veces la recesión se le considera
al decrecimiento de la actividad
económica durante un periodo de tiempo
expertos dicen que se registra una
recesión Generalmente cuando la tasa de
variación del pib es negativa durante
dos trimestres consecutivos Pero qué
podría causar este decrecimiento pues la
verdad Raúl Existen varios factores pero
para el caso puntual de este año lo que
podría pagar una recesión para 2023
sería la elevada inflación que ha
registrado en muchos países de manera
consecutiva las políticas monetarias que
adoptan algunos gobiernos las secuelas
económicas de la pandemia del covid 19
que muchos expertos le han llamado a
esto el efecto rebote y pues este año en
particular la guerra en Ucrania que
afectó las cadenas de suministro y causó
desabastecimiento finalmente algo que no
se puede sacar de la ecuación es los
precios de la energía que también lo
hemos discutido muchas veces aquí el
equipo de economía de France 24 junto
con nuestra compañera Alba Santana habló
previamente con Ilan goldman director
para el hemisferio occidental del fondo
monetario internacional él nos dio la
definición exacta de lo que es una
recesión y lo que puede esperar para las
economías mundiales el próximo año
bueno recesión significa que el
crecimiento de la actividad del pbi
es menor y se va cayendo la recesión la
verdad es un ungimiento negativo para el
ciudadano común significa que hay menos
empleos en el sentido de que tiene que
buscar un empleo nuevo va a tener más
dificultades y algunos van a tener que
pedir su empleo porque no hay tantas
oportunidades como como teníamos antes
eso pasa en momentos a donde hay
momentos de ajuste en la economía Qué es
lo que creo que va a pasar el próximo
año no queremos que vamos a tener un
ejercicio negativo Pero vamos a tener
una desaceleración que la diferencia es
que no se quedan tantos empleos como
anti las decisiones cuando los empleos
empiezan a perderse la gente Empieza a
pedir sus empleos o sea una recesión
técnica es un pbi negativo en dos
trimestres Juan Pablo también se conoce
que la recesión podría afectar primero a
las grandes economías Como por ejemplo
Estados Unidos China y algunos países
europeos Qué pasaría en nuestra región
Pues sería un efecto completamente
particular que nos lo explicó nuestro
invitado incluso desde la guerra en
Ucrania cuando llegó el
desabastecimiento en algunos países de
latinoamérica Pues en realidad se vio
beneficiada a nuestra región de esta
situación pues empezó a exportar mucho
más de todas estas materias primas que
necesitan mucho muchos países de Europa
y Asia y que pues acá son muy ricas algo
parecido podría pasar con la llegada de
una recesión sobre todo con el
fortalecimiento del dólar que cada vez
es mayor escuchemos
cuando el alza de los precios significa
que los productos que estos países están
exportando
y generan más dólares generan más
agradación y eso es bueno para el
balance de pagos tienes más dinero
tienes más reservas puedes importar más
y además tiene un impacto en la economía
que la economía se queda con mucho más
capacidad de consumir de invertir en
estos momentos entonces lo que llamamos
nosotros el un un shock de términos de
intercambio positivo y
eso es lo que pasó a los que venden las
comodis las comodines la pueden meter a
un peso mayor eso al final beneficia de
todo toda la economía
si llega esta recesión Juan Pablo ojalá
que no quienes podrían estar preparados
para esta crisis y además que deberían
hacer los gobiernos pues Raúl nuestro
invitado del fondo internacional
monetario internacional nos explicaba
que lo importante es tener instituciones
sólidas que las políticas Fiscales y las
políticas monetarias de los países vayan
en sintonía con la situación de la
economía del país que sigan los
parámetros comunes o más usados para
controlar la inflación que también los
hemos mencionado aquí como el aumento de
las tasas de interés y que no se
desborden con el gasto público sobre
todo con los mercados que ya están casi
completamente recuperados de la pandemia
del covid 19 Esto fue lo que nos dijo
lo más importante es que tengamos
capacidad recaudar más en países que
tienen la declaración baja para poder
tener
los servicios públicos adecuados a las
poblaciones entonces en muchos países
los recursos que se tiene son muy bajos
comparados a los países del mundo en
estos países te necesita recaudar más
para poder tener mejores bienes públicos
y hay varias formas de hacerlo y un
sistema más progresivo o sea un sistema
que protege que tiene protección a los
va vulnerables es mejor en términos
equitativos pero también tenemos de la
pobreza
Juan Pablo Muchísimas gracias por toda
la información económica más adelante
por supuesto más así es Raúl Seguiremos
atentos de lo que pueda pasar con una
recesión global gracias a Juan Pablo
nosotros pasamos a saludar ya con toda
la información de los deportes